what's happening there reject nation we
are going to watch today toby maguire
reacts to spider-man no way home trailer
2 dub now in case you didn't hear me
correctly or read the title let me
clarify and make this explicitly clear
for everyone here
this is a hundred percent real this is
definitely toby mcguire you're gonna
hear it in the voice you're gonna be
like wow can't believe tony maguire
actually sat down and did this making
his confirmation in this movie that much
more real
yeah guys check out gom films who
managed to snack till mcguire here just
to get him on camera for this one
reaction let's do it
[Music]
so this is
that movie
i can't talk about we have one week no
where my life is
that was when you found out
hey i used to do that with my mary jane
i miss her
when you botched that spell where you
wanted everyone to forget the peter
parker spiderman i'm sorry i forgot the
part where that's my problem
[Applause]
oh that's dr octavius he's
he's cool
wait
he is remembering
remembering me
cool
what was your name
[Laughter]
okay seriously i want to take this kid
and throw some dirt in his eye
there you go this black suit's giving me
flashbacks
[Laughter]
i
no you shouldn't
hey that's jj man he still owes me some
stakes for taking
some pictures
christmas movies
hey i remember throwing one of those in
harry's face now those were the good old
days
[Laughter]
don't
i don't know anything
okay how are these guys even a threat
man me and harry would have beat
these guys pretty easily
oh please tell me that's harry coming
back man i love that guy
he's trying to steal mj oh my god
um i guess harry is a jump
psychic
i can't save everyone oh what's wrong
spider junior you're gonna cry
you're gonna cry
oh oh tommy boy don't go pulling off
andrew garfield
[Applause]
looks good what's happening
they're starting to come through
and i can't stop him well mr strange let
me tell you you want forgiveness get
religion
number 29 spider
it's not hard
i am spider-man
i am
[Laughter]
george my man george my man i'm glad to
see this video is taking off for you i
missed the days though when the dislike
button was around because i loved seeing
how many people just would not read the
title of your video and hit dislike and
then you go to the comments to confirm a
lot of these people clicked on it
thinking that it was not a dub when it
says clearly that it's a time it makes
me so happy but hey man this video is
taking off dude over half a million
views 26 000 i got to send you a text my
friend it's funny talking to george on
the phone because he he has that voice
head accent yeah i don't know what that
ever inquired with that
where are you from george he lives in
america he has a family business out
here won't go into details as to what it
is hearing his voice hearing was like it
always sounds like he's a foreigner yeah
but he's not
maybe it's because he just keeps
changing the delivery pattern and the
cadence but this is really funny dude i
love that you took mainly spider-man 3
quotes and applied it here and how you
also managed to imbue it
with toby having this nostalgic love for
harry osborne throughout how all this
was just going to man harry and i would
have killed their asses
yeah it really makes you like
reminiscent of those old glory days as
much as james franco is a creep it makes
you think of the simpler times you know
when they brought those characters first
to life this takes a lot of hard work
man and i'm so proud of how far you've
come we got where your subscriber count
at right now 98 oh my god guys 100
subscribe to gom films he's almost had a
hundred thousand subscribers from what i
remember him tommy this took like nine
hours for him to put together i believe
it because i think the interview that
this comes from is pretty long
so like to pick all the right moments
and stuff like that yeah you got to try
and match it up with all the dialogue
and i believe he'll sometimes have some
lines in mind that he's going to try to
make
fit or squeeze in and he can't prep this
in advance he's got to get the trailer
first to know what to work off of so
it's just a major instant hustle for him
yeah he's a hard worker it is like silly
and goofy as this is it takes a lot of
work so kudos to you man i'm glad this
is taking off guys subscribe to gom
films if you haven't done so already ah
spiderman no way home gonna miss the
lead up coverage so much